[Music]
that's me
Ruby McGuire presidential advisor
[Music]
judging from the camera candles and
sexual paraphernalia I'm guessing we
have a rogue pornographer on campus with
a penchant for a satanic bondage erotica
probably trying to cash in on the big
money world of co-ed nudie films
apparently they have a library card and
that tastes for VHS tape there's no tape
in the camera he covered his tracks well
the slippery squatter know the slippery
squatter a con artist masquerading as a
student living in the dorms tending to
Isis all tuition free I'm gonna strut
for two years now and every time I think
I'm getting close he slips through my
fingers how do you know it's a squatter
because the squatter always leaves
seaweed snacks in the hideout
oh my god the slippery squatter is a
myth officer McCoy some students left
some sex toys in the basement as part of
a prank or I'm not Dean Gina mcdougal
Steve gene mcdougal steamed Dean of
Students at former professor gene
research they've Journal seen and Roy
where lovers once until their romance
came to an ignominious end the squatter
is as real as you and me he's gotten
cocky and now he's gotten reckless he's
making adult films right under our noses
just give us two days a week and nail
this guy no I am NOT perpetuating some
crazy myth that there's a student who's
foamy and making sexy videos from campus
not during finals week well we have no
come clean Jane this is about you and me
no I'm over it
McDougal Steen is blind Rory we can nail
this guy together I can't have you
getting involved in this Ruby not with
mcdougal steam breathing down my neck
it's too risky
but I can help you you're a college kid
Ruby it's finals week focus on that
sharpen some ticonderoga's huh look at
some scantrons prepare yourself leave
the detective work to me
[Music]
this is a 1993 VHS copy of the romantic
comedy cannibal potluck starring Joshua
Jackson and Juliette Lewis who was the
last person to check it out Bobby so
cool
Bobby Sokolov a friendless germaphobe at
the bottom of the campus food chain
rumor has it he can only go peepee in a
passive toddle Bobby art Carlyle Bobby's
teammate on the Raritan University
mathletes former teammate I haven't seen
Bobby since he quit the mathletes why'd
he do that
shacked up with some girl TR name some
wannabe that's okay I mean we were on a
three season winning streak we were
stacking checks we were cashing checks
we were checking boxes I was checking
out chicks it was the why
are you looking for him we have reason
to believe that Bobby's been involved in
the production of unauthorized adult
films we found this VHS he checked out
of the library of the crime scene
figures ever since he got a girl he
thinks he's hot last time I saw me
he called me a douche to my face just
because I'm a 17 year old whiz kid who
happens to be really passionate about
math does not make me some kind of a
little okay maybe I shall have
that just in case Bobby shows up this is
actually evidence in the ongoing
investigation all right then you should
bring it to his film criticism teacher
you don't know what to do with it
can Charlie get you anything water
coffee
dr. dumpling and his TA Charlie fiddle
I'm good thank you
well I am just disappointed by all of
this Bobby is one of my best students
and pornography he loved our curriculum
what was that exactly
obscura nineties romantic comedies that
explains the VHS I found at the crime
scene
Oh a cannibal potluck the tour de force
yeah art said you're gonna drop this off
with us it's actually evidence in the
ongoing investigation
when was the last time you saw Bobby
well I haven't seen him for a week
because of finals but I think he's in a
study group with Belinda back belinda
back what year is she I'm not sure but
she's one of my brightest students how
do you spell that no sooner in by the
name of Belinda back here are you sure
she's auditing in class
dr. dumplings history of obscure 90
cinema nope no sooner in by the name of
Belinda back at riots in the university
mrs. McGuire I just had a conversation
with a member of the film criticism
department and apparently you've decided
to continue with the investigation
because I'm an RA and I'll be damned if
I let someone shoot dirty movies and my
born house arrest will relieve you of
your curiosity
[Music]
I'm sorry about all this Ruby it's my
own fault I just can't turn it off
can i I'm sorry I make a good team I
know the squatter is real if we don't
find them I'm gonna go cuckoo bananas
you can still find them no Bobby knows a
squatter you know Bobby you've got the
best shot at cracking this thing what
are you saying I'm saying you
overpowered me you stole my mace you
sprayed me in the face and you tiptoed
on out of here
no right yes Roy this is the way it's
gotta be
but they'll have your badge for this I
traced the video camera to a repair shop
downtown last resort' video a real dump
you can pick up the trail there Roy wait
good luck Ruby
- water Ruby
[Music]
how could you let her get away before
you oh man I love this old things the
handle can give you really bad carpal
tunnel put our last forever
any idea who you sold this to I can
remember how to ask my colleague Belinda
Belinda back this slippery squatter
herself why can you answer you damn song
I'm so sorry we were cramming for finals
Belinda's boss let us crash up here we
studied look it wasn't us Glenda and I
don't even like those give me one reason
I shouldn't haul you in for trespassing
right now it costs 40,000 a year to go
to Raritan I can't afford that she ha
did some class isn't it has to crash in
the occasional at the one that doesn't
make her a bad person then why was the
movie you checked out from the library
at the crime scene cannibal harlot I
thought I lost us months ago but was a
beautiful name does anybody like this
doing it a crazy it gave me the VHS
player
uh-uh it's like
abstract fondant
[Music]
okay okay fine fine fine fine if there
is somebody recording avant-garde
bondage pornography here on my campus
that they all got masks on so there's no
way to tell who they are
au contraire this video proves that the
mastermind behind the underground
bondage porno ring is in this very room
Tina tinkle joy and polynomial tinkle
joy productions recognize your
letterhead charlie Tina tinkle joy is
Charlie fiddle pseudonym or should I say
nom de porn the cue believe it what
can't you believe art or should I call
you polynomial that's just a coincidence
is it a coincidence that the vintage
video camera found at the crime scene
happens to cause carpal tunnel what
about the seaweed free with the purchase
of a camera at last resort video they
must have enjoyed a salty precoital
snack so simple so addicting why we did
don't you do it because I needed the
money
you walked away from a fortune and
mathletes prizes okay you left me in the
dust I'm just an 18 year old student
trying to make his way through college
who's gonna pay for my tuition haha the
moon and you I am so sick and tired of
90s romantic comedies I wanted to make a
thesis film that would discuss your
tastes as much as your taste disgusts me
I had no idea you felt this way
Hey Ruby's no prude probably but if you
two want to get your rocks off shooting
some low Phi erotica in the privacy of
your own home be my guest but as soon as
you cut a lock and breaking it out of
bounds own in my school you broke some
rules bucko mcdougal stain let the Dean
and mcdougal steamed to you Roy art
suspended indefinitely and Fiddle
terminated effective immediately why are
you surprised your Accord upon with a
student in my buildings what about Roy
Oh
Roy Roy Roy can you not do that Froy
[Music]
reinstated ah slippery squatter
I know they're involved in this who is
it I'm sorry where I can't I made a
promise to someone I mace myself II
thought we understood each other
perfectly
guess I was wrong
[Music]
another whodunit solved another
wrongdoer laid there another layer of
skin peeled away from this rotting
corpse we call a student body till next
time
[Music]